Hausa Gomez - welcome I guess
and I'm here with you
are you making fun of me see you were
sick I'm sick in all ways but we're
gonna play gentlemen's dispute it's
gonna be the best time I've ever had
comments so this is a dispute between
two gentlemen based on a true story
let's play go I am the blue wine this is
me don't come near me
ah what are you doing I'm sorry sir but
I do believe God or your [ __ ] is in the
Time Attack Oh God I don't know but it
charges and attacks and it's amazing
what is he Jim I don't know sir but I
don't believe that it doesn't quite work
it attacks with the hat goes
ha-doo-ken Oh the gentleman has spoken
oh god what I'm dancing what yes my hat
is so much better than your sir
I do quite infallible lambda2 but sad
that sir
oh my god oh I'm sure quite frankly
believe that my hat it's more what my
hat my mustache was born out of your
mom's very nice personality oh yes and
oh oh thank you baby oh oh how do you do
that awesome you're swimming crazy
don't stand on top physics
cuz why not boom shacka lacka i was
really good BAM oh I do Christ actually
I do believe I am the best in general
I mean don't you say you're way younger
than me plus you look more like in the
old way I eat well and I work out it
works
hey just cuz you lost this one we can do
one more try to be more efficient you
are the one who lost we would do 10
water
oh really oh really
bring it Brittany I'm just gonna stay
here hey I'm just gonna chill here for a
while wait no no oh no bull crap oh you
make fun of me make me wanna don't wanna
what love don't stand on top of me
you like it I love like how they keep
their fingers because it's a gentlemen
dispute you don't fight you just dispute
yeah use your heads
I don't believe my mustache is better
than yo sure no mine is more Russian
well your bouncers okay
that's why I reveal your baldness what
that's what I do
they are you bald you're bald
oh no my haircut every work so long on
it wait I love how they walked is what
is too heavy for them do you think like
a million steps we should go shopping
why fight what are you I'm gonna come
dancing I'm Jan Jane I'm gay Jane I'm
dancing oh oh
backflip backflip boom oh if we both hit
it stop what you win
bull crap oh you aren't trying you
overestimate me okay final one whoever
wins this one is everything in life when
you say about me bro will you stay by me
brother did you have poetry reading
without me yes oh
I'd how could you you know I've written
poetry just tell me that you didn't
dream team that just tell me that you
did not drink tea with her
please read then I guess I'm so good
what are you doing walking on top I
don't know how to even check you know oh
you got a little bandaid on your bold
skull that's adorable
oh that judged oh I hate you I always
hate you
Wow what are you trying to do
what if you do it it's fine if I go
angry it's not what Oh What's Up now I
wonder what we're actually te all busily
yeah that's the only thing gentlemen
cares the outside of tavern said she
died waiting tea oh my god oh oh oh my
god a shower chance
oh my god what's gonna happen Wow rounds
whoa oh my god
Oh gentlemen I'm a gem I'm the best
gentleman oh my god madam bashing but um
and what a mansion really but amazing
love this is oh right uh my Mustang oh
are you guys your bite on that listen
guessing you mean it's okay because we
all know the true winner is whoever's in
real gentleman in night clothes me yes
thank you
now you win so you have to since you
lost you will have to hey Jason anyone
sees you lost I'm not gonna do that
oh okay I'll let you set me ones just to
prove that I'm a gentleman nice and
remote
how does he work exactly I want to kill
you you will probably kill me good
doesn't work okay isn't this I'm worried
I'm gonna hurt you no nothing much okay
so since - as a gentleman elbows up or -
well I cry I'm sick you're living okay
how scared you had today oh my god
kiss cam so much are you okay okay I'm
Elaine look at that like a meter
watching this guy who every day I was
like I'm gay